Tôi biết đường năng tròm ngày 11 mồn đe gió khởi kẹp đã BBC với yêu cầu bụi thường ít nhất một tỷ
lạm ý sau khi đại chuyện hình con cóp anh thường nhận xa lầm miếm trọng trong phản đoán
khi bên tập một đoán phát biểu của ông, liên quan đến vụ bạo loạn đôi capital năm 2020
theo lỗi dùng bước thường gió nhỏ rất sư của ông tròm giữa BBC,
mù phíng tay liệu phát sống trong chưa trình phản đồ ra ma đã án ghét nổi bạo đoán video
khiến khán giả hiểu lầm rằng ông K-1 Gõi Nội Rai,
phíng trăm cáo vộk BBC có tình các mò phần đông kèo gọi người ủng hộ tần hành un hòa và yêu nước
đông thời cho rằng hành động này là vô khẩm và mặng đồng câu chính chi trước kể bộ cử giữa kể của Mỹ hành hình hai sau
BBC đã gỡ film con nên tạo chực viên ipleo và xí lỗi vì các miền tập về Ấn tượng xa lầm
sẵn bác mò cáo vộk có thêm kiện hệ thông,
cho tình BBC xa Malaysia cho biết,
đại đang xem xét phản hội pháp liy và khẳng định,
sự công bằng bất là giả chi có tỏe của BBC,
sự việc xa xa trong bối cảnh khổng phản đồng bộ tại BBC sau khi giảm động điều hành chim
David và tạo b hit up da bộ ra churnes từ chức hông của chi đoay một gió sự app về
cáo vô kênh lệ chông các bạn tìm liy và quà để ông trăm và xung đồ dài gà ra,
chính phù anh tình bộ bất ủng hộ nhà đại nhưng kêu gọi BBC khó phục nhìn tình công trủng và tôn thủ trận mật mạo chi cào cấp nhất.